Jesse Palmer ESPN college football
analyst also host of daily male TV and
the national spokesperson for two
nonprofits the National pediatric cancer
foundation and good sports and Jesse
Palmer joins us good morning Jesse how
are you doing okay we were trying to
figure out this Ohio State situation
where that's a bad win for Ohio State
against Maryland now you come home
Michigan's waiting Michigan's supposed
to win Urban Meyer looks miserable on
the sidelines
who's the pressure on in this situation
it's definitely on Ohio State down I
think there's no doubt about it I think
my biggest concern for Ohio State really
is probably twofold I think in order to
beat Michigan one they've got to play a
complete game offensively and
defensively and I don't know if we've
seen Ohio State do that this year and
secondly they've just got to play with
more emotion and more energy and
enthusiasm with a sense of urgency yet
that's probably to me been the the
biggest shock and the most surprising
things surrounding Ohio State when you
consider that this was the number 10
team heading into this past weekend it's
still very alive in the college football
playoff race ever since there a lot to
Purdue they just kind of seem like a
team that's that's moping around they're
kind of starting off these games very
very slowly and then give them credit
you know waiting games are finding ways
to win but if they're going to be the
number four team in the country at home
this weekend to keep their playoff
chances alive they got to play a
complete game and they've got to show a
pulse yeah which which we haven't seen
them do now is since probably they went
on the road and played Penn State what
do you think Urban Meyer's future is
well you know I'm not a doctor I don't
know what necessarily what his health is
you know I think that's his dream job I
think that's a job that he'd love to
have as long as he can have it and I
agree with you I mean each and every
week
you watch Ohio State you watch Urban
Meyer on the sidelines and he just looks
like he's in agony I mean mentally he's
just he's obviously very very animated
he's very invested you know I read the
reports and I read the articles every
week talking about you know you know
this could be it how much longer can he
go
I really believe that Urban Meyer wants
to go for as long as he can I think
at the job I mean he just seems perfect
there and that's a place that that you
know I imagine him you know ending his
career as a fan of college football you
know I know so many people would love to
see him you know continue to have
success and finish up there but I don't
know what itself is so I don't know how
much longer he'll do it I was impressed
with Notre Dame against Syracuse and
granted it Syracuse but this is a better
incarnation of Syracuse football and
even their head coach said boy if they
continue I mean they dominated Syracuse
aside from the bad uniforms they're how
I mean how good is Notre Dame compared
to Clemson and Alabama
so I think there's a gap after Clemson I
to me I think Bama and Clemson are far
and away the two best and most complete
teams and most dominant teams in college
football but what I will say about Notre
Dame is that I don't see you don't see
very many weaknesses when you look at
that football team and to me you know
the fact that their unbeaten the way
they're playing on offense now that Ian
books has taken over a quarterback and
after that performance against Syracuse
that was the number 12 ranked team in
the country that was a statement when to
me this past weekend especially when you
consider the rest of the top four teams
all struggle this weekend including
Alabama against the Citadel so you know
for Notre Dame what do you like the
unions are you don't by the way I did
like them I wish the helmet may have had
like Andy Andy and the Yankee scripture
calligraphy why would you split the
finishing touch on it but to me that was
a very very impressive win and I think I
think Notre Dame is a team I mean pretty
amazing what they've been able to do
this year and especially when you
consider their schedule these past
couple weeks having played Navy and San
Diego and then going to Yankee Stadium
to played Syracuse now they got to go
all the way back across the country to
play USC in a rivalry game if they go
unbeaten that is very very impressive
and their death easily are one of the
best four teams in the country is Jesse
Palmer ESPN college football analyst
joining us Dan Patrick show I brought
this up a couple of weeks ago that we
look at Alabama
I think Alabama is boring I love to but
they're so boring Lee great they remind
me of the San Antonio Spurs that you
know what whenever the Spurs would get
in the finals people go oh the Spurs are
back
they represented everything you would
want in a team that leadership great
coach Hall of Famers they play hard play
to both end they did all the things you
want it just feels like Alabama is like
they're just not exciting they're just
Alabama
am I being fair to Alabama they're
unexcited ly dominant excitedly great
yeah ya know it's funny it's funny to
say that I have a lot of friends that
that'll you know kind of text me heading
into the weekend every week and oh say
which game should I watch excluding Bama
I'm not going to watch I'm not going to
waste my time and turn the television on
to watch them beat a top five team by 29
points I'm not going to do it and it's
it's just it's just I mean I said this
for weeks now I think this is the best
team this year that Nick Saban's had at
Alabama I think this year's team would
be any of the other five national
championship teams they've had I think
the biggest differences you mentioned is
to uh and just how explosive this
passing attack is that's something I
mean you look at their wide receivers
and their tight end and they line up
across the board and they've got NFL
dudes everywhere that can win
one-on-ones we've seen in years past you
know Julio Jones and Amari Cooper and
you know Calvin Ridley and you know
they've had one great receiver this year
they've got like three true sophomores
in a tight end that all look like
they're their top three ran tags and
they're just there's just no week
there's no holes there's no weaknesses
and you say okay well who gives Alabama
you know a game and right now I think
it's I think it's Clemson and that's
kind of it that's kind of what I see so
I mean you're not the only person out
there that you've just seen you've read
the book before you've seen this before
from Nick Saban and bam is it a foregone
conclusion Golden State wins the title
or Alabama I'm gonna say I mean when
Steph Curry coming back I'm gonna stay
down I mean like to me and I thought
this week three I was like this is this
is week three week four I said this is
the best team next Saban's had if they
stay healthy then they're gonna win a
national championship in my opinion now
listen I mean to his health every week
is a question mark and you know Jalen
Hertz is banged up a little bit of
quarterback too so anything can happen
you know and and you know there are some
spots on defense or Alabama
not particularly deep so you never know
it's going to happen they've got two
really physical games coming up against
Auburn and against Georgia but to me I
mean you know it's you know Clemson
Clemson looks looks great Notre Dame we
just talked about Michigan's defense
looks fantastic but to me it's it's Bama
and than everybody else and it felt like
it was - and everybody else for the
Heisman but I'm starting to lean a lot
more to Cuyler Murray with my Heisman
voting yeah I am - and I'm like you you
know just the more I've been watching
he's it's crazy to say this but I think
statistically he's actually playing
better than Baker Mayfield did a year
ago but of course he has a completely
different dynamic and element with his
running ability and I think Cuyler
Murray's the only player in college
football history to average over 300
yards passing and 60 yards rushing per
game I guess that's what 4.6 million
dollars looks like that athleticism he
has and his ability to run around and
being a first round pick by the Oakland
A's but that's a totally different
dynamic and that's kind of the funny
thing when you watch Oklahoma their
defense is so bad yet their offense is
so historically good and it's it's
because of Kyler Murray you can you
cannot I mean what you cannot argue is
that Kyler Murray is way more valuable
to his team than tua is to his team
Alabama would still win 10 or 11 games
yeah you know if they didn't have to uh
but you know but Oklahoma might not be
well they wouldn't be a 500 team I don't
think if they didn't have Kyler clay
Helton survived at USC I think so
because of the success they've had in
recent years having won the conference
having won a Rose Bowl obviously this
year not what was expected they knew
they'd be behind the eight ball a bit
with a true freshman quarterback in JT
Daniels still the expectations should be
and are very high especially in a pac-12
South Division that is is so up and it's
so wide open
really so like ohio state like Alabama
like it's like Oklahoma like these other
programs around the country that just
expect to win their division they expect
to go to the playoffs
like Clemson every year this has not
been the type of seasoned USC was
anticipating but I don't think I don't
think this year is enough to help lose
his job who has more jobs you or Ryan
Seacrest Michael Strahan I fancy
national cowboy more jobs and you do and
you do too I think no no I gave up I
gave up a couple of them yeah but you
opened a school okay well fair enough
but I I cashed in a couple of those jobs
there just to spend more quality time
with my family of course well you know
if and when I ever get to that level
where I can do that and start and if you
ever need like like a substitute teacher
someone to just come in and just give a
speech at your school I mean I'd love
read Berggren can set that up okay we
would love to have you come in and you
know we we dub I'm trying to think we'd
give you an honorary degree if you
wanted that too Jesse thanks for joining
us Jesse we appreciate your time awesome
thanks for having me on
that's Jesse Palmer for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]